- [Man] The word non-profit
scares me a little bit
but it freaks the hell
out of my parents.
Have you ever wanted to
do something that you knew
there was little to no money in
and can you offer
myself any advice?
- Yes. No, I've never
wanted to do that.
(laughter)
You can keep the mic
for a second but
it's really interesting timing
that you ask this.
I'm on the board of a
non-profit called
Pencils of Promise.
And POP was started by an
unbelievable young man
named Adam Braun.
Adam Braun's brother
happens to be Scooter Braun
the guy who discovered
Justin Bieber.
Here are two brothers
and they went in very,
very different directions.
Now imagine your bro
who's a year younger or
older, excuse me,
in this scenario
not only didn't go non-profit
but went and fucking
found the Biebs.
Right?
And made tens of
millions of dollars.
He's run POP for about
a decade and now
he just got married a
couple years ago
and not making any money
has gotten to a place in
his life where he's already
done more good for the world
than 99% of people and
he's now going, he's just left
and he's now our
Chairman Emeritus
but he's no longer involved.
And he's going and
trying to build
what he now needs financially.
I'll tell you this,
we've never lived through
a generation where young people
are willing to go that path.
The cliché path is the way
I always thought about the way
I was going to give back.
Right? Build a huge empire.
Buy the Jets and then
start giving back. Right?
I got affected five to seven
years ago by Scott Harrison
who's the founder
of Charity: Water.
Also very
progressive non-profit.
And he said, "Gary, you
can give along the way.
"You don't have to build
it all up and give it away."
And I've done that.
And it's been very
rewarding to me but
as a lot of you know,
I don't talk a lot about
my non-profit work.
I think, there's a lot of things
I keep private.
My kids. You know, it's funny,
I keep all my good shit private,
you know, I just do.
It's just how I roll
but I don't think anybody can
tell you how to live your life.
You just need to make sure
that you mean it.
So I have a lot of 23,
24-year-olds,
22-year-olds right now
that don't know exactly
what they want to do and
they've painted a narrative
that they want to be
a non-profit because
they like the brand association
of making themselves feel
like they're better human beings
than the other people.
I'm not joking.
You need to make sure
is that what you're doing or
do you actually want to do it?
If you actually want to do it,
you go head first but
if there's a part of you that
likes the narrative that
it paints on you
as a human being
and you're concerned about
the other parts like
money and other things,
you don't have to beat
yourself up about that.
(light music)